hallo mein name ist luca und ich mag
sand das ist jude bin ich deswegen haben
wir hier unfassbar viel kinetics kennt
meine lieben freunde hier haben wir
trace magic zellen wir haben hier so
einen kinetics and castles wir haben
hier noch zweimal beach sind keine
ahnung ist und dieser sand wird torben
als magischer sand noch so sympathisch
wir haben ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung
was uns hier so richtig erwartet wir
haben keine richtige challenge
eigentlich wollte die beiden eine
sandburg bauen und gucken hat insgesamt
baut
allerdings wollen wir erst mal machen
wir das jetzt erst mal auf ein paar
sekunden später das ist einfach nur
gefärbter sand ich habe ein auto bei mir
drin
autoscooter als alles was du hast kannst
du dich bei mir entschuldigen
dieses video ist übrigens nicht
gesponsert von der marke die die magics
kennt macht allerdings würde ich sagen
wir schauen uns diese sand jetzt erst
mal genauer an einen büroraum schroten
dann haben wir schon eingefüllt und so
sieht er aus also es ist so eine
mischung aus knete und sagen würde ich
sagen bleibt gar nichts an händen kleben
juli muss kacken leute auf jeden fall
haben wir uns dem ziel diesen gesamten
haus geparkt in der ein verpackung war
heißt eine blaue box mit blauem samt und
hier war halt so eine gelbe box mit
roten sand ich glaub ich hab ihn gern
dann auch noch mal rein so jetzt habe
ich hier orangen mit gelbem sand und man
kann es wirklich von der konsistenz
komplett gar nicht beschreiben es fühlt
sich an wie trockene knete weil sand ich
meine das ist total komisch ist manchmal
gerade hier ein bisschen dran also so
ist die konsistenz
das ist auch ein juli wacken ja also das
ist auf jeden fall der magische sand
sein ich dachte jetzt irgendwie leuchtet
er vielleicht im dunkeln leuchtet der
sand ist jeder war der lukas und denkt
sich magischer sand was das denn muss
mega krass sein kann ich ja mal ein
video darüber machen jetzt machen wir
das stinknormaler das sieht schon dass
sie schon ästhetik aus
nein ist alles voll mit sand dass sie
total interessant aus guck mal das ist
von außen mega so zusammengedrückt aber
dann so als wenn man da irgendwie
abgebissen hätte als wenn das ein
schwamm wäre das wenn du sachen siehst
du willst erfolgen einfach mal rein
weißen ich würde da folgen
ja wie dein leben ich war gerade kuchen
ich habe jetzt mal den ganzen stand er
bei mir in dieser komischen verpackung
drin was zusammen geformt und das hier
gemacht was soll das sein
20 sandkörner geld gegen ein bisschen
blau ok christ einstecktuch
nein ich will mir ich hab dir voll viel
geld gegeben gelbes wir selten als blau
wie wir wie sollen die konsistenz
beschreiben
ok ich dachte das wäre so mega cool und
jetzt könnten wir das richtig geiles
bauen und dann habe ich hier so ein kloß
scheiße und der zeit fällt auch noch die
ganze zeit mein gott
alter schwede lasten leicht darin ihr
sand möglichkeit dieses videos die sich
eine rein zu enttäuschung aber ist ja
immer ein ganzer kanal sie kriegt in
ihrem leben nichts auf die kette der
grüne sahen kommt auch die mit rein und
der liederner hier selbstverständlich
auch in den restlichen blauen dann
packen wir auch noch hier vorne mit rein
applaus unsere leistung der mit ihr alle
verschiedenen sandfarben formeln was ich
auch immer variationen keine ahnung was
zusammengepackt man eine große stade
werden das jetzt mal komplett
durchkneten und dann sehen wir uns in
drei jahren wieder wenn wir einen
regenbogen sand haben irgendwann später
wenn wir jetzt gerade alle sanft haben
die wir irgendwie hatten also orange
gelb rot lila blau und grün zusammen
gemischt und es sieht so aus also leute
ich weiß jetzt dass auch der kamera
richtig rüberkommt aber kein scheiß
sieht heftig neues aus und vor allem
wenn man dann mal den sand hier so nimmt
und hier so runter fallen lässt oder
wenn ich jetzt mal ein bisschen mehr
nehme hier schaut euch das an dass das
schon da kann man schon mal leichter
lassen ich bin ganz ehrlich ich bin hin
und hergerissen ich weiß auch es später
so kaputt gemacht ich weiß nicht was ich
davon halten soll also irgendwie der
ganze sand haben wird der papst relativ
gut zusammen als er hinterlässt
eigentlich ist keine rückstände gegen
den ecken und jetzt sieht schon mega
geil aus also wir haben alle möglichen
sandfarben hab ich ja ganz schön
erzählte zusammengepackt und jetzt
freikommen wie das aussieht jule alter
das sieht so aus als wird das umwelt
jetzt der fans komplett
also es ist schon ich meine schaut euch
das an
es sieht schon das sieht schon heftig
nice aus also mag ist es nicht aber es
sieht schon rechtzeitig verein aus
es ist auf der einen seite irgendwie
cool up anbieter sein wird dem mann
kollegen die das bauen kann und den man
auch zerschneiden kann sonst wenn er ja
auch keine messer bei und so was alles
aber auf der anderen seite ist halt
immer noch sand und seien deshalb
eigentlich relativ langweilig wir machen
mal kurz und kleinen magic saint pol
[Musik]
sieht schon ein bisschen aus wie bunter
durchfall ein verrat an der stelle mich
dass heute videos als ob meine damen und
herren
wie gesagt wir hatten einfach so sechs
sieben pakete von diesem krejcik zellen
und haben einfach mal getestet haben
hier steht auch drauf auf der verpackung
knet sind also vielleicht also ist magic
cent aber irgendwie ist es eigentlich
nur knet samt hier steht halt dass der
run kombinierbar ist in verschiedenen
farben die kinder hier sind auch super
die zeigen was ihr bei dem video machen
sollte und hinten steht auch noch mal
ganz genau beschrieben was man quasi mit
den sachen machen können also irgendwie
sieht form und was da drin ist und so
viel sand war darauf gar keinen fall
[Musik]